Do you feel like you're working harder and harder these days just to stay
financially afloat while fat cats get richer and richer.
It's not just a feeling and you're not alone.
The income gap between rich and poor in America,
is that an eight year high?
That's the largest differential since the period immediately proceeding the
great day.
Passionate.
They're getting more while the have nots are getting less.
Meanwhile,
government isn't helping.
Decades of rising inequality
fired.
Wow.
Oh,
recording.
Wow.
Matthew being run out of job.
Gosh,
Dang.
Wow.
Hey
tomorrow.
Welcome to the program.
My name is Glenn Beck.
The bad news is just multiplying.
Our economy is tanking.
It doesn't show signs of improving their people.
Losing jobs are government responds to a the problems with bailouts and when you
call them up and say,
what are you doing?
You don't get any response or not listening to you.
Wall Street owns our government.
What did we get here?
I think a lot of people feel like they're alone and they just want to give up.
Wow.
Are you love my country?
It is the shining example of a place where people work together in peace and
friendship and worship God and make things better together.
Wow.
Well,
the idea that built America are being lost and perverted,
man.
Wow.
Ask yourself this one question.
How many Marxist Communist anticapitalist do you have around you on a daily
basis?
Yeah.
The truth is that you are the defender of liberty.
Our situation is bad.
There are Nazis in America,
Nazis and communists.
You have to think like a German.
June,
1934 the higher.
Hi.
Wow.
There is a perfect storm formulating and it is here we are entering a dangerous
and scary time.
America,
the country will be washed with blood.
These people don't mess around.
They are taking you to a place to be slaughtered.
Death camp.
What planet am I landed on?
It's like that damn planet of the apes did.
I slip through a worm hole in the middle of the night and this looks like a
mirror.
We're in a dark,
dark place.
We've got some dark dudes coming our way.
Black Panthers,
Acorn,
reparation,
welfare.
Jeremiah Wright jumps on my himself.
Alcaide Ram Islamic Jihad is breasts.
Venezuelan immigration,
Mexican was refugees from laws,
Spanish,
[inaudible],
America,
legal,
alien,
Mexico.
Every one is coming.
Enemy is not only in the gates there inside the house,
but again as BIA most come up,
Regan pestle.
Oh,
La Maxim.
Erica.
It's like a pack of wild clue.
Joe's ripping up the flesh of the American people.
Drug Lords,
illegal aliens,
Mexico.
They're going to start getting more and more violent.
We had been tossed into boiling water.
These people are cannibalizing,
cannibalize.
That's what Barack Obama is doing to the American people.
I'm hoping the guy with horns doesn't actually show up.
Okay.
Everything is about to change to the extreme,
the insider extreme.
We invite you to join up for nine 95 a month.
It's going to explain everything that is going on.
Welcome.
Yeah.
Hi.
Insider extreme is up and on.
Hello?
Yes.
Sick,
twisted freak and welcome to the extremists.
Who are you?
Why not?
Why isn't that a name of some stupid Disney?
You can ask any question.
Oh,
sucks to be you,
doesn't it?
When you bought a house,
you back that you could pay it,
that nothing would happen.
It happened.
You lost.
Move on.
Boohoo cry me a river.
Hey,
I got an idea.
Listen to this,
isn't it?
Get a job,
Lazy Slob that refuses to get off the couch and get a job.
All
right.